was a shocking upset have you heard in a
congressional primary it could have
major implications for the Democratic
Party Alexandria cassio Cortez
please remember that name she defeated
ten term Congressman Joe Crowley in New
York last night he is the number four
House Democrat and was considered a
potential successor to Minority Leader
Nancy Pelosi cameras captured Acacio
Cortes screaming as she saw the results
come in she was an organizer for
bringing Sanders presidential campaign
and as recently as November she worked
as a bartender alexandria Ocasio Cortez
joins us now on the telephone
good morning I know you won by about a
15-point margin why do you think your
message resonated with voters well I
think a lot of working-class Americans
and voters here have been waiting for an
unapologetic champion for economic
social and racial dignity in the United
States and we provided a very direct
message a very clear message and voters
also knew that I was the only candidate
in the race that did not take corporate
money in a time when economic
marginalization is really increasing in
New York City so I think it created a
lot of trust in our community and our
message really inspired a lot of folks
that don't usually turn out and off your
midterm primary use part of your message
oftentimes when there are these kinds of
shocking wins that that to shake the
establishment the messages to the
establishment do you have a message for
the Democratic establishment in
Washington yeah I think that it's time
that we really need to reassert and put
them truly put the needs of
working-class Americans first we
shouldn't be afraid of bold policies
that chart a vision for the future of
America that that we want that will be
just for everyday people trying to make
ends meet Alexandria I think for a lot
of people who were meeting you for the
first time it was that video last night
where you looked as surprised as
everybody else you put your hand over
your mouth like oh my gosh I can't
believe this is happening to me so I
would like to know what that was like
for you and what were you thinking as
the night went on yeah you know I said I
had not checked the results
we had driven over to this party with
our supporters and I had not checked the
results at all I was not following them
in the car and you know we started I
started walking over to the little
billiard place where we were gonna watch
the result and essentially what had
happened was you know we saw on the
screens that we were up and I ran inside
and I ran into a TV set and looked up
and saw exactly what the results were
and and it was just so shocking we had
felt so great all day but but to see
what that feeling looked like and in
numbers was really astonishing did you
think you had a real shot at winning I
always felt like we had a shot and that
we had a possibility to win always from
day one Alexandria one other quick
question there's a debate in the
Democratic Party right now about those
issues you talked about working class
families and presenting resistance
against President Donald Trump what's
your message in terms of the way
Democrats should talk about those two
issues in the campaign well I think that
we shouldn't be afraid to go toe to toe
his administration is a form of
extremism and that we should be very we
shouldn't be afraid to be very bold and
very strong in our values and be very
clear-cut and what those values look
like in policy and legislation
all right Alexandria Acacio Cortez
thanks so much for being with us